a
[Música]
cómo
es uno de los países más difíciles para
ejercer el periodismo reporteros sin
fronteras al ubica en el puesto 148 de
180 como uno de los peores para la
libertad de prensa en venezuela se han
registrado casos de detenciones y
agresiones físicas de las que no escapan
mujeres periodistas que también han sido
blanco de campaña de descrédito en redes
sociales como la que enfrentó
recientemente una comunicadora en el
estado aragua que fue tildada de
terroristas de la prensa tras compartir
información sobre la escasez de camas en
hospitales públicos a propósito de la
pandemia por kobe 19 pero al mismo
tiempo acceder a fuentes gubernamentales
en este país es prácticamente imposible
también en los últimos meses el
canciller de venezuela jorge arriaza ha
enviado cartas de protesta cuestionando
la línea editorial de agencias y medios
de comunicación internacionales
y un diario local es uno de los más
importantes del país el nacional de
línea muy crítica del gobierno fue
condenado a pagar 13 millones de dólares
al 'número dos' del chavismo tras perder
una demanda por presunto daño moral
[Música]
el ejercicio del periodismo en méxico es
de alto riesgo según distintos
organismos internacionales la
clasificación mundial de la libertad de
prensa que establece reporteros sin
fronteras pone a mexico en color rojo
que implica una situación difícil el
país se ubica en la posición 143 de un
listado de 180 países sólo un peldaño
abajo de la india- y solo 5 arriba de
venezuela la organización artículo 19
reveló que el año pasado se registraron
692 agresiones contra periodistas y
medios de comunicación un incremento de
14 por ciento respecto del primer año de
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
artículo 19 ha señalado que en sus
conferencias mañaneras el presidente
aplica una estrategia de división y
estigmatización con descalificativos
como prensa fifa o pasquín inmundo hacia
distintos medios en contraste el
mandatario acusa que artículo 19 es
financiada por eeuu y se compone de
conservadores que están contra su
gobierno asegura que en su
administración ya no hay censura a pesar
de ser el dice el presidente más atacado
por la prensa en 100 años
[Música]
colombia es el quinto país de américa
latina más hostil para ejercer el
periodismo según un ranking mundial de
reporteros sin fronteras en el país
andino siguen siendo frecuentes las
agresiones amenazas de muerte y
asesinatos de periodistas en el día
mundial de la libertad de prensa
organizaciones como la fundación para la
libertad de prensa publicaron un informe
sobre el alarmante auge del acoso
judicial contra periodistas colombianos
140 casos registrados entre 2018 y 2020
pero además las mujeres periodistas
sufren de manera desproporcionada
diferentes tipos de violencia y acoso
sexual tanto en su trabajo como en
entornos digitales en los últimos 10
años seis de cada diez informadoras
colombianas han sido víctimas de
violencia de género en sus espacios
laborales de acuerdo con una
investigación de la unesco tres de cada
diez de reporteras del mundo han sufrido
un tipo de violencia en la red las
organizaciones colombianas denuncian que
las violencias que enfrentan las mujeres
periodistas son el reflejo de los
problemas de sexismo estructural en la
sociedad
[Música]